let's go next to our caller from the 469
area code who's calling today from 469
hello David my name is Anna Rose can you
hear me
yes Oh first of all congratulations on
your show and you had a great decade my
question has to do with you you know I
think nuclear policy with Iran so our
primary goal foreign policy objective
was to prevent Iran from getting the
bomb
you had Obama's idea of beyond nuclear
deal and you have both of the idea of
kind of bomb Iran or invade them so my
question is is that bad of a problem for
Iran to get the bomb because we seen in
other states like India and Pakistan
once where they get the bomb
they actually have become less
confrontational India and Pakistan only
fought one war against each other after
they both got nuclear weapons and that
war that was basically a border skirmish
that lasted about two months so is it
possible that if Iran gets the bomb they
might be more open to negotiation that
might curb their finding of Hezbollah or
other terrorist groups I just want to
know your opinion about this because I
don't hear a lot of people discussing
this opportunity so a couple things on
that I mean number one anytime that
people start saying this country should
or shouldn't have nuclear weapons it
gets - okay well who gets to decide
whether that is or isn't the case and
then there's a conversation about the
validity of the United Nations Security
Council and who are Americans who have
tons of nuclear weapons to tell another
country they can't have them that's a
debate and let's put that aside so we
can actually deal with the question that
that you're asking if I were to say what
your what you're suggesting is
completely plausible but what might be
different in Iran I'm open to having my
mind changed but it seems that the
powers that be in Iran are different
than those in India and in Pakistan
would you say that that is a material
difference in exploring this or or maybe
not I'm not exactly sure about that the
interest I don't think that because that
means Pakistan and Iran or both Islamic
Republic's they both are very hard
religious streets but at the same time I
as much as Pakistan India the leaders in
Pakistan rabbets on nuclear but don't
hate Indians that much that they say
the more than being loved living
themselves because nuclear weapons are
such a short way of mutual destruction
that no one is going to use it and
anytime you clear powers are at conflict
they will always be escalate to
negotiation oh yeah this is not so so I
actually it's not discussed enough and
it should be and it is something that
I've read about and it's at least at
face value it is a practical
consideration I'd have to do more
thinking about how it would apply to
Iran specifically but it is not a crazy
thing to suggest yeah but my question
for this tone because I realized that
you have to spend a lot of resources on
burning a lot of bridges trying to
ensure that Iran doesn't have a nuclear
bomb whereas I think that it might be
more productive if instead of focusing
so hard like focusing on reaching out to
Iran or trying to do like hearts and
minds campaign to these tensions between
the countries rather than trying to keep
Iran it down in a situation where that's
harmful for the US as well it's a very
fair point and I appreciate you making
it I'm going to think more about it and
maybe it'll be worthy of a of a
follow-up discussion I really appreciate
the phone call a sorry to everybody I
already get to this year but we will
take calls again in 2020 before you know
it it'll be here we'll take a quick
break and be back with much more right
after this